today our present in the application
crisper cast nine implants
my name is cinema thanks very much
Lapras give me an opportunity to pattern
in my work first CRISPR is a very
popular tool for gene editing already
first now I talk about the mechanisms of
CRISPR the customer looking at the SGI
as a dual complex can create a double
strand break in the chromosome which
would induce mutation through the 19
repair system in the South it's easy to
show that the CRISPR is very popular but
still you need the same actor to deliver
CRISPR system into your interested
autism my hair are present might respect
our system that should be interesting
for plant research community and
secondly our present my PSP master the
for decoding CRISPR kazna induced
mutants sorry every display what is DFT
stand forth in my following as last the
first common component of crisper Stra
so we designed this as jayanna
intermediate vector they include the SGR
a promoter and a CR my backbone and
polity terminator since it's very small
so it's PUC 19 based vector we cloned
for as GM promoter for Monaco's OSU 3
OSU 6a OSU
be an OSU 60 you can use these promoters
for Monaco's plants then we could clone
the fall as GM promoter for the die
cause like eighty you three beer eight
years three year eight years six one and
the 1806-20 not those promoters are
better to use for that cause brands in
order to integrate your target Oh
interest to the intermediary actors you
can you you can sense as the adapter the
lab get to your a street to our
intermediate vector or you can use
overlap in PCR here I'm to mention
because the cassette overall it's very
small is John the January's along the
500 base pair 20 whisper who is very
small so here we are using PCR to
amplify it instead to accumulate the
first name in this way you can assemble
multiple Austria to set by PCR a same
time which is a very convenient so next
step is the custom hat has nine the big
eyes around the for Sultan the
nucleotide protein secrets but you do
not need to change it and have the
information is located in SG army but
her apart so we are doing this work for
you so based on sir
SP a nucleotide sequence and amino
sequence of Casman we could optimize it
for plants and attendees and and 99 or
lab particles to assemble the customer
code in sequence with nuclear
localization signal attached on both and
then we confirm the cast man express our
word our krishna expression and the
localization with in
port protoplast the system here you can
see we attached the GFP a coding
sequence to the cosmic set with its
drone but you'll be creating promoter
then we transfer the transfer this
constructor into protoplast that you can
see the geophysical with local as the
only in the nuclear area which were the
chromosome also present so that they
kept in touch with each other and to the
gene editing work after establish that
the cosmic said we in security the
insta-family reactor system data you do
not need to any change you do not need
to do any change on eight regarding the
selection markers is always a matter
that our people do in transformation
need to take Carol because didn't primes
met a prefer different selection and
particle selection method here we have
virtual entity to each PT and bad gene
selection so that the basically that
means it have three workers so that you
can choose which one would you prefer
and for the customer code in sequence
you can find UB creatine promoter worker
and the certify as promoter virgin
so in total we have six abandon records
for you to choose from
add gene website for for the clue means
as GRI cassettes
we have PSA one said to PSA was as
indicated in the panel vector and so
that you can integrate 2 to 8 as TM
cassettes simultaneously using the code
engage acromion
Messer if you are not familiar with
recording it Clooney you can refer to my
publication later our also included in
the reference part with this CRISPR
vector system so we apply transferred to
the plants and we got a lot of mutations
then we can tango unless the mutation
character out in Uzbekistan has seemed
one half of the mutation it's a single
base pair insertion and the remaining
are mostly small additions this is
important because for for us to for the
second part of the DSP method for
decoding the CRISPR induced mutations
were using were Youkilis the street so
here is an example mutates mutant
mutations we were cat from CRISPR so
what actually here to dress sequence the
word have the hair we designed at the
the tag is in the boat sequence and we
got two mutant alleles no tabs within
the deploy plants we win when we want
amplify this happied region they were
innocently forefinger sequencing we got
the Comerica from micrograms upstream of
the mutant I said it's totally normal
and the clear Peaks but downstream the
mutation new knee rotation area is
overlapped peaks if you look clearly
they are the combination of the mutation
the earlier one and
in the alley O'Toole yeah this this is
the interesting and obvious but what if
he only had superimposed the
chromatograms and you cannot read it
directly so that's why we are deep he
went in the DSP master first we all we
summarized the category that mutant taps
into foul tips cancer shell R and
another allele can be a skill we wear
tab or deletion or repetition always a
single nuclear insertion us and the
deletion but all the stuff if you send
it for sequencing of any fingers
frequency so all the overlay or they all
have already Peaks starting from the
mutation set of course you can a chrome
the PCR product and then send it send it
of our sequencing with multiple clones
so that you even across the ten you can
know exactly what the mixed PCR because
I'm kickin mixture can be but this can
be costly and nothing efficient enough
so person we are already thinking can we
decode this overlap chroma chromatograms
with all the frequency without further
Klum wait and the same thing the first
multiple crews for sequencing and
eventually we went to this master called
the generator sequence
decoding what you do is once you get the
Comerica
superimposed chromatograms you'll find
the anchor seek set which is a stream of
over Peaks around 15 a base pair and
then you manually feeds the overlapped
Peaks
and design convert into degenerate
sequence for example you can convert a C
and the T into y si an
a into M C and T into y again and the
next step your queries raffle credits a
degenerate sequence to the reference
sequence once you fun hate you drunk
as the head with the anchor sequence in
this way you can tickle the earlier one
and then you subtract earlier one the
blue part from the degenerate sequence
I'm acually you know dakotas falconer
leo across this method we used for many
for tackles plants it could be in grass
this method we use the firstly we
maintain demand our manually manner but
a lot of our users are not satisfying
about this I think I do tedious and
require a lot of energy to if you have
hundreds or thousands or sequence for
decoding so we decided to develop the
web a software to address this problem
it is called T as decode m and we which
is elapsed by dr. Sheehan Lucia we
worked together in addition to this tool
doctors here also integrates other
passive empty tools to that you will be
used when you are applying the CRISPR
system implants for example if you want
to find which parts you can use for this
for design you Christopher
Happy's you can you study design too and
if you want you're not sure about
signing the articles or primers you can
be used for pretty far for the puppies
we can use the primer design and if
you're worried about of capital that
potentially face the other
no sir or genome you can use the
off-target tool to to make sure that
your targets are specific enough with
the CRISPR vector system and the value
from a tool called CRISPR te we applied
this to the systems the into in dress
which is many phone calls from from my
previous lab well in control here the
rest there is a pollutant no stress you
caste is Milky and but the rest
generally we have found from the market
the a semi-transparent there only one
genes as different in front from the
normal dress and the gluttonous stress
the ratio to candle starch amylose and
amylopectin amylose is a so the ratio
what a ratio is 20 to 30 percent the
normal rest and the worst least slow
what's agnostic 50 or very low content
is collusion of Russ the gene
responsible amylose synthase sweats gene
which is already were whirling carrot
red welfare so we give the order to
create routine no stress even from auto
normal racer artist in a fast and
efficient manner
so we designed two topics and in the
extra outer
west gene and then which has found rest
it's in the T 0 generation which is the
the first generation of Trustees we
already called routine note up to
handles a grouping of stress that means
the to Leo of action are both happy
Peter then we
the middle content and then we found
that indeed the amylose content is
comparable to the earlier - already -
available gluten no stress from the
market they are not distinguishable
synapse interesting question and also
the powerful part of CRISPR that the
attacking the target that you designed
is if you're talking of course but a
transgene cassette that there will be
integrated in the genome which random
that think that means that they can be
separate segregated from each other so
they are here I will show you why we
can't segregate the transgene the
transgene that include that contains the
cast and cassette from the mule from
your mutation or your interest firstly
since the its random
that means if worried if most likely
that key DNA and that the target are not
linked with each other from the left
from the left in Spearfish in caste that
steal after one generation was starting
that 1/4 of progenies will be trusting
free well use the content mutation of a
lot of people ask you asking well
sometimes it can be possible that the
CRISPR cassette will be dink will be
interpreted in the target sag and they
will be linked with the charger and
Hawkeye separated but we have to
remember that the plants are generally
deployed or polyploid the even the
cosmic said are linked with the router
deals
the odds are utterly leoch has no
security wins without problem now
stealing from the illustration on the
left on the rat Cassie one of also
trustees still
the progeny with you because Jean free
faith really powerful part of gene
editing here is an example of how it a
segregated the transgene fragmented
bazaar fee Cassie to of the protein
lands the one to ten they still have
trans gene and the one two three two one
already lost on each particle resistance
that means such as gene part is gone and
but but when we honor disease from three
to one glance you can see still Latinos
rest that means the mutations there but
the transgene part is already segregated
with blood this vector and constructor
to multiple laboratories and they
applied to other Marie interesting
species for example tomato rapeseed kiwi
fruit content popular extra here is some
of the publications they the some
publications resulted from our
construction so the kicked home message
is that we developed a crisper vector
system that is user-friendly and
accessible through and gene so that the
general actress without any molecular
experience can still use this Raptor
system and the secondly we developed the
CRISPR de porc a default for you to
design the CRISPR experiment and mutants
from from the crispity Aditi the plants
and here is references from which I use
the team presentation and if you are
interested in more information regarding
CRISPR or I'm at least as I'm seeing
from a protection that
explained clearly you can refer to my
review paper the CRISPR Costner platform
between gibt plants developments and
applications without actually marker
plant okay I think that's off for map
rotation Sankyo
Airport therefore listen to my talk and
the SATs
Lapras for giving me the opportunity to
present here thank you